Film Courage: We had a comment that came in
which said [in response to a video interview]
“That’s easy for this person to say because
this person is a professional screenwriter
and it’s their job to write all day.
It makes sense to say it’s your job (kind
of like get over it, just do it).
But most people that watch the Film Courage
[Youtube] channel [Which is very nice that
they think this] are not professional screenwriters
they actually have other jobs that have to
pay the bills.
Screenwriting is a hobby for them at best
while they make the two worlds work and that
I get.
So no…you don’t have to write everyday
to be a writer.”
Mark Sanderson: I don’t write every day.
I do when I am on assignment and then when
I’m not, I’m kind of exhausted.
And the last year has been crazy I mean with
like 6 movies so it’s like almost every
3 months turnaround.
But it’s fantastic because I was constantly
writing but it’s draining.
It’s almost like I want to go do something
else and stop.
And they say “Well, when you stop the assignment,
you want to go work on your spec.”
Like not right now because I don’t have
the time you know?
But you have to manage your time, you really
do and there is no excuse.
I’ve had to do it when I was in college
in film school.
I was working 4 to 5 nights a week in a restaurant.
But I had friends who went to film school
or any college and they could just go to school.
They had the luxury of living at home, their
parents paid for everything.
I had to pay my bills.
But I think that trained me into really sectioning
my time.
Yeah you can go to parties and all this stuff
and I was not only making movies in film school
but I was also after day class I had to go
down (I was working in Westwood here) and
work a 5-hour shift and then come home.
So it really trained me for that.
And there’s a million excuses why we don’t
want to write.
I mean truthfully when it’s difficult, even
more “Oh, you know?”
Like I said, I never have the house as clean
as when I am procrastinating.
But the movie I just turned in on assignment
was my 35th screenplay.
It’s still learning, I still respect the
craft and bow down to it because I learn something
every time.
Every project is different, every producer
or company you work with, it’s a while different
scenario each time.
Yes, you know how it works a lot better.
I look at old scripts now and like my 4th
spec (my 5th one sold), my 4th one made some
noise.
We met with the A-list actors about it (this
was a million years ago) but I looked back
at that script and I was like “Arrgghh!
If we’d only, if I could only go back and
rewrite that with what I know now but you
only have the knowledge that you have this
exact moment in time and you can’t live
with regrets, so study, get better, write
more screenplays.
Yes writers write, but I don’t think you
should feel guilty if you’re not writing
every day but don’t let it go two days because
two leads to four, four leads to a week, this
weekend we’ve got something going on, you
have to schedule it and I always say to aspiring
screenwriters, treat it like your job because
it will be.
You don’t have the luxury of when you write
your specs to go “Uh, I’m going to go
off today.”
Work on it for 5 minutes, 10 minutes, whatever
it is.
But that constant is what is going to happen
when you get the assignment jobs and you don’t
want to be shocked when suddenly you get this
opportunity, you’re hired to write a movie
and you can’t physically sit there for 8
hours a day or you can’t write it in 30
days or you can’t write it in 8 weeks or
however much time you’ve agreed to write
the screenplay.
You will be shocked because you’re not training.
The same thing as an athlete or you wouldn’t
go run a marathon without training for it,
same thing in my opinion, in my experience.
And so if you’r going to spend the time
writing your specs, train yourself now for
the (hopefully) for the time that you are
going to be hired to write screenplays and
then you’ll be much better.
But again…yes…coming from a thing that
this is all I do for a living but that’s
where you want to be.
And like I say, I better damn well be doing
it 10 hours a day if that’s all I do.
Film Courage: It seems like maybe some jobs
are more draining than others.
And I know it’s easy for me to just say
“Oh, well just find a job that’s not draining!”
And I know that’s easier said than done.
But I think there are jobs where you can have
sort of a side other job or slash hobby and
there are jobs where it just takes you out
of it, it’s so demanding.
Mark Sanderson: And the thing about that is
it’s going to take you that much longer
if you can only write on the weekends, how
long do you think your screenplay is going
to take.
It’s going to take 6 months.
You know, I mean that’s where the time creeps
in and there’s so many other distractions
and interruptions that come in that 6 months
that are dangerous, that will derail you so
quickly and go “hmmm.”
That’s where you have to…I would dig deep
and say “This is what I want to do and there’s
nothing…”
That’s where the passion and the tenacity
come from that really drives you through all
those other, through the field.
You are going to step on that - Kaboom!
And that sets you back 3 months.
It’s really difficult.
And yes, you are right.
When I worked at the law firm for 2 years,
it was draining.
And I would come home and have to write again.
But it was even worse because I had a movie
go into production while I was at the job
and again it wasn’t enough money to quit.
And so I had to excuse myself and say “I’m
going to go to the set for a few days this
week because I was an as needed assistant
type position and that was again (even years
later) a freaky thing going “But why do
I have to work at the thing?
I’ve got a movie.”
And then you look at the thing and you go
okay I get it.
And then I stayed on it for another year at
the firm and do the same thing.
Come home, make dinner, write, you know, blah,
blah, blah and then I got a call from the
production company that I worked with (the
new president of production) and they said
“Hey!
How come we haven’t worked with you since
the last movie?”
I said “I don’t know?”
They said “We have this fast track movie
we want you to write.
It’s a done deal.”
And I gave my 2-week notice.
I was like this is my kick in my pants that
I’m back in without fear not like “Oh,
well…”
And the money was good at the firm.
But I was seeing myself be derailed and I
had a relationship at the time (my girlfriend)
and I saw just everything was being derailed
and I thought well I could just get into this
and you know, another year go by and…
So when that call came in from the company
I was like “I gotta go.”
And they were shocked.
They were like “Well…well…I guess this
is what you do?”
And I said “Yeah.
This is what I do.
I’m a writer.
I have to go do writing and it’s a job.”
And they said “You are always welcome to
come back.”
And I said “Exactly.”
Like when I finally quit the restaurant business
when I got my first job, it took me 6 years
out of film school before I landed my first
professional writing job and I thought when
they handed out the diplomas they were going
to give me a 2 picture deal.
“Oh thank you very much.
Oh look at this?”
6 years!
And that’s not for lack of writing and specs
and all of that stuff.
I finally landed a job so I gave the notice
at the restaurant and they were like “Huh?”
They didn’t quite understand and they were
like “So how long is this job for?”
And I go “No!
I’m out.
O-U-T.
Not coming back.”
I said “I appreciate…there’s never again
will I step foot…”
And I didn’t.
I mean I did catering but that was sort of
less of a, you’re in different places.
But I was never going to work…I worked 10
years in a restaurant.
I did many odd jobs in my life, I say in the
book.
Many different jobs but it was all about facilitating
me being able to stick with my dream, whatever
the job was, as long as it allowed me to continue,
I didn’t care.
It wasn’t embarrassing or you know.
It was like you have to do what you have to
do.
Film Courage: It reminds me of the movie I
just watched IT’S A WONDERFUL LIFE.
So Jimmy Stewart he thinks I’m going to
go off and see the world and then go be an
architect and then gets sucked back in 2 years
or 4 years at the bank and it keeps…life
changed for him.
Mark Sanderson: It’s hard.
It really is hard.
But as I say it’s hard, I am living proof
that it does happen.
And there’s no guarantees but I always say
the only guarantee in screenwriting is that
if you should stop writing, you’re definitely
guaranteed never to have any chance at success.
So as long as you’re in the game, you have
a shot.